ich probiere heute all diese Influenza
Produkte zum ersten Mal
[Musik]
wir starten mit lombie Cola von Pietro
Lombardi ich bin sehr gespannt lombie
Cola Cola Zero die schmeckt irgendwie
wie ein bisschen weniger süße Coca-Cola
Zero bisschen was von unserem calippo
Eis insgesamt nicht ganz meins ich gebe
ihr sechseinhalb von 10 sie ist vor
allem wirklich nicht so süß probieren
wir die normale Cola
eigentlich trinke ich viel lieber Cola
Zero
kriegt noch nichts
oh die ist wieder süß bisschen brausig
im Geschmack gefällt mir aber besser 7,5
von 10 werd mal einen Blick auf die
Rückbank Leute ich habe zwei fette Boxen
robs crunchy Puffs eigentlich schon aus
eigentlich schon ausverkauft aber Rob
hat extra für mich noch mal welche klar
gemacht ich habe einfach ein paar
blockprodukte gegen ein paar crunchy
Pubs getauscht
wer die crunchy passt nicht kennt es
sind Flips die aber doppelt dreifach
vierfach so groß sind anscheinend sind
die Dinger echt riesig und entweder
Hanni und cheese oder spicy Paprika ich
würde sagen wir starten mit Hanni und
Cheats also Leute machen wir auch wow
die sind wirklich groß guckt euch das
bitte mal an normalerweise ist so ein
Flip so ein Drittel der Größe würde ich
sagen die riechen wirklich käsig aber
wir wissen Käse teilweise sind die sogar
noch größer guckt euch das mal an
richtig krank my Snack Hanni und
schießgeschmack probieren wir super
crunchy
die zerfallen einfach in deinem Mund das
ist 100% so ein süchtig machen das nicht
von dem du immer mehr und mehr und mehr
nehmen musst weil dadurch dass sie
aufgepufft sind so viel Luft drin ist
willst du einfach mehr in deinem Mund
haben die sind wirklich gut Drops Chips
sind ja offensichtlich sowieso krass
aber ich würde fast soweit gehen dass
ich nicht weiß was ich mehr mag die
Chips oder die Papst weil wirklich
brutal bedeutend geiler als alle Flips
die ich je gegessen habe liebe den
Formfaktor dass die Dinger so groß sind
das ist für mich eine neuen von zehn ich
bin gespannt auf weiß die Paprika mir
noch besser gefällt
weiter geht's mit Paprika ist
hoffentlich wirklich bei sie finde sogar
man muss auch sagen für Chips sind die
relativ gut gefüllt weil jeder kennt
glaube ich so diese diese in der
Chipstüte nur so viel Chips drin sind
das ist so groß wie ein kleiner Finger
also wirklich ordentliche Dinger ich bin
gespannt ob die wirklich scharf sind
100% schärfer also Standard Paprika
Chips für ein Schärfe erprobten Mann
kein Problem auch sehr sehr lecker aber
Hanni und cheese hat mich wirklich von
Socken hauen ich gebe dem spicy
Republica 8 von 10 eins steht fest jetzt
brauche ich ein 5 wo formaggi klingt
schon direkt italienisch capital bra
Pizza habe ich schon mal getestet hat
mich sehr positiv überrascht vor allem
wegen dem knusprigen Boden gucken wir
mal was diese neue Sorte drauf hat fünf
käse-mix Nachos Style Käsesoße manchmal
sind genau diese Sachen die beste
vegetarisch Special Edition
[Musik]
also
Produkten sind Leute blockbrett Block
craper und Blocks Salz Box meine
Produkte sind noch im Shop verfügbar wir
haben extra viel bestellt so dass jeder
auch eine Chance hat die Sachen zu
bekommen schaut mal unter dem Video da
seht ihr sogar auf Youtube direkt die
Produkte integriert könnt ihr euch
anschauen und bestellen wenn sie was für
euch sind das ist immer wieder
ernüchtern ne wenn man eine TK Pizza aus
der Verpackung wird das sieht irgendwie
jetzt aus als
würde man sich mal unbedingt essen
wollen aber ich finde es aber muss ich
sagen schon cool das ist auch mal ein
food Produkt ist also wir haben ja schon
gesehen gerade auch im Intro die aller
aller meiste Sachen sind einfach Drinks
12 bis 14 Minuten dann gibt dir
12 bis 14 Minuten ab in den Ofen
fertig ist die Pizza die sieht wirklich
sehr unitalienisch aus augenscheinlich
soll die Pizza aber auch gar nicht
italienisch sein weil normalerweise hast
du ja quattro formaggio also vier Käse
das ist ja 5 € von Major deshalb würde
mich wirklich interessieren ob capital
bra auch nur ein Wort zu der Entwicklung
von dieser Pizza beigetragen hat klappen
wir uns ein großes Messer und schneiden
das gute Stück einmal an es sieht klein
aus aber ich glaube dadurch wie viel
Belag wir haben wie viel Teig wir auch
haben ist das gar nicht so klein wie es
aussieht und käsig ist es alle Male
sieht auf jeden Fall pervers aus
irgendwo formaggi teamkapi der Boden wie
wir ihn kennen fast so ein bisschen wie
ein Cracker gucken wir mal wie es
schmeckt
jetzt habe ich gehört der Boden ist
wirklich eine geile Innovation der
bleibt einfach so schön knusprig obwohl
die Pizza so dick ist das ist so eine
Pizza die muss man essen wenn man schon
sechs Bier hat dann schmeckt die
besonders gut
schmeckt besser als die aussieht 5
verschiedene Käsesorten also die
schmeckt jetzt nicht so zu käsig oder so
der crunchy Boden reißt auf jeden Fall
was raus aber es ist eindeutig eine
Fertigpizza das Sucuk Pizza also viel
mehr viel besser auch die mit
Grillgemüse war geil aber was mich ein
bisschen stört ist dass die trotz 5 Käse
eigentlich am ehesten nach einer
Margarita schmeckt wir haben viel Teig
und die Käse haben jetzt nicht irgendwie
so ein unterschiedlich Geschmacks Profil
sondern das ist im Endeffekt eine
aufgeblasene Margarita deshalb gebe ich
sieben von zehn und ich bin schon wieder
zu nett das ist eigentlich eine 6 von 10
die Pizza hat mir auf jeden Fall den
Rest gegeben ich brauche jetzt erstmal
eine Erfrischung werde zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben überhaupt vitalwelt trinken
ich habe noch nicht das normale
vita-welt probiert ich finde ehrlich
gesagt die Flasche sieht cool aus oder
das Vita Welt Logo
Eli aber ein sehr netter Mann der auch
gerne mal hier zuschaut das hat liebe
Grüße auf jeden Fall die Diskus
probieren wir als allererstes denken
cool nicht so zuckerhaltig
erinnert mich direkt an dieses Wolldecke
Hibiskus ist mein erster Gedanke ich
probiere
boah ein Segen zwischen den ganzen
Getränken die wir heute probiert haben
etwas was einem nicht die übelste
Schelle von Süße gibt einfach wirklich
so ein Tee das gefällt mir wirklich
wirklich gut bisschen Zucker ist sogar
drin 3,100 ml das geht voll klar also es
ist ein Tee Getränk man darf nicht
erwarten dass es ein die
Geschmacksknospe zerfetzt aber auf der
Tee getränkt Skala ist das sogar echt
eine 9 von 10 für mich zwei Sorten haben
wir noch Kaktusfeige und Pfirsich
bringen wir erstmal die Pflicht hinter
uns für sich das ist so wie ein weißes
T-Shirt wenn jemand eine Modemarke macht
das muss einfach dabei sein riecht nicht
so krass da fühlt sich wieder z.B dirty
nicht so gut wie der erste nicht so gut
wie Hibiskus auf keinen Fall weil es
irgendwie nach weniger schmeckt
siebeneinhalb von zehn weil es immer
noch geil ist ne so dieses zuckerarm und
so schmeckt mir gerade erfrischend gut
aber sie hat und zu guter Letzt
Kaktusfeige Kaktusfeige gibt sogar auch
relativ häufig bei Eistee probieren wir
auch geil besser als für sich acht von
zehn außen ist es heiß Kühler Getränke
was können uns jetzt noch besser
erfrischen als ein leckeres Eis das
nächste Produkt ist eigentlich ein
doppeltes Influenza Produkt bzw Promi
Produkt weil wir Marshmallow Candy Eis
von Sandra das ist aber von Ice Cream
United was wiederum die Eismarke von
Lukas Podolski ist lasst uns gemeinsam
reingehen you never Schleck alone man
sieht auch poliert daran mitgewirkt
Zutaten frische Milch frische Sahne nur
natürlicher Raum mit Kirschsoße wir
waren gerade immer bei den Kalorien pro
100 ml 112 Kalorien die machen auch
wow ich habe nicht mit dieser Farbe
gerechnet alter Schwede das sieht sehr
intensiv aus deshalb gut dass da steht
nur natürlich herum weil die Farbe sieht
auf jeden Fall krass aus da sind echte
Marshmallow Stücke drin ich erwarte auf
jeden Fall einen sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr süßes eiserlebnis boah das
erinnert mich krass an etwas es geht
sehr stark in Richtung bumbum Eis würde
ich einfach mal sagen die Kombination
von der Hülle von der Vanilleeis innen
drin schmeckt so wie das hier es ist
aber nicht mein Geschmack so Marshmallow
Candy würde ich mir glaube ich niemals
holen wenn ich bei der Eisdiele stehen
würde aber es ist sehr gut umgesetzt
also es macht Spaß wenn man sich
anschaut die Stücke innen drin sind nice
es ist auch weniger Papst süß und so als
man denkt ne wenn man sich anschaut weil
das sieht so aus das wird gar nicht
lange das Ding ist es gar nicht mein
Geschmack aber für das was es ist ist es
wirklich gut deshalb würde ich
persönlich der ganze Sache siebeneinhalb
von 10 geben darauf habt ihr alle
gewartet und auch ich bin sehr gespannt
vor mir stehen die drei
Geschmacksrichtung von Energy
montanablacks Energy Drink der nicht
Zero schmecken soll und wirklich
außergewöhnliche Geschmacksrichtung mit
sich bringt mal hier ein tolles Detail
oben drauf der goldene wie nennt man das
Ding Digger die goldene Flaschen Lasche
ich bin gespannt das Internet streitet
sich auf jeden Fall über diese Produkte
hier und ich bin gespannt ob sie mir
persönlich schmecken werden ich glaube
raspberry Cheesecake machen wir ganz zum
Schluss weil das ist glaube ich der
kontroverseste Geschmack probieren wir
tropical exotic first edition bei Monte
kann man sich auch ins Regal stellen
wenn man fertig getrunken hat machen wir
mal auf das war zum großen Teil die
Inspiration für dieses Video weil ich
wollte einfach wissen wie es schmeckt
das riecht zu 100%, wie so nimm zwei
Bonbon probieren wir
okay schmeckt man dass es Zero ist ja
also ich finde man schmeckt definitiv
das ist das ist jetzt nicht so Augen
öffnen nimmt es ist ein geiler Drink
erinnert mich von der Süße ein bisschen
an diesen weißen Monster den irgendwie
jeder trinkt habe ich das Gefühl der
auch so bei Fitness Leuten irgendwie
beliebt ist mein Favorit Zero Energy
Drink ist Red Bull Zero aber nicht
dieser blaue sondern der dunkler also
das ist ein Unterschied den löst es für
mich auf jeden Fall nicht ab ich würde
sagen Sie mal von zehn für tropical
exotic weiter geht's mit Blueberry
Coconut ich habe Leute gesehen die haben
gesagt das alles übelst geil ist andere
haben gesagt du musst nicht sein und
viele haben gesagt Kokosnuss in Drinks
muss nicht sein deshalb bin ich gespannt
ich muss sagen geruchlich liefern die
alle ab der hier raucht wirklich übelst
geil wie nimmt zwei der hier hat so eine
schwere Blaubeer Note es macht schon was
her probieren wir Blueberry Coconut
Blueberry Coconut steht drauf und ist
auch drin ich fühle den Punkt das
Kokosnuss ein bisschen weird ist weil
man trinkt was und plötzlich hat man so
ein Kokosnuss Geschmack am Gaumen
gefällt mir besser aber nicht viel
besser acht von zehn unser letztes
Produkt das heutigen Tages Gönner die
raspberry Cheesecake besonders auf den
Geruch bin ich gespannt riecht wirklich
nach einer Himbeersoße und auch hier ist
wieder wirklich mutig finde ich der
Geschmack Cheesecake Energy Drink und
dann auch noch in so einer Stückzahl
hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht jeder
getraut
mein Favorit bleibt auf jeden Fall der
hier also ich verstehe warum der so
kontrovers ist der schmeckt einfach wie
nichts anderes das ist einfach schwer zu
vergleichen weil Cheesecake so wirklich
dieser käsige komprimierte Geschmack von
einem geilen Käsekuchen so der Gaumen
zusammen klebt da fehlt einfach was
finde ich wenn man Cheesecake trinkt man
sollte immer probieren weil ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass es ein gesch auf den
liebst du wenn du ihn liebst und wenn du
nicht liebst dann holst du dir einmal
und nie wieder ist für mich eine 6 ist
echt nicht meins acht siebenhalb sechs
Freunde das war auf jeden Fall einige
influencer Produkte die ich zum ersten
mal probiert habe meine beiden
Tagesgewinner Vita Welt Hibiskustee und
Rob scrunchy passt honey und cheese
wirklich wilde Produkte dabei gewesen
ich ziehe mein Hut für jeden von den
Kollegen die ein eigenes Produkt
rausgebracht haben und nichts davon was
nicht wert ausprobiert zu werden deshalb
teste worauf ihr Lust habt wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
ciao ciao